aber ich möchte ich eine eine sache
fragen sie sie sagen ja dass das wir
kämpfen müssen und dann sagen was
wirklich meine sprache spricht sie
würden also nicht für die ukraine dann
selbst in den krieg ziehen aber die
schweren waffen
altersbedingt in gar keinen krieg mehr
wissen sie vielleicht nur in einen krieg
für ein besseres klima aber nein das ist
nicht der punkt der punkt ist ein punkt
ist dass wir jetzt ein diktator
ermächtigen mit einem anderen land zu
verfahren wie er will und dass mit
diesem überfallenen rand das recht
absprechen sich zu verteidigen und das
wird
doch genau dass man wissen wenn wir ja
sagen müssen wir auch b sagen das heißt
wenn wir jetzt die ukraine zudem die
gewinner auch weiter unterstützen und es
kommt dann doch dazu müssten sie ja
eigentlich sagen ich wäre auch bereit
das dann auch deutschland mit zieht in
den krieg sonst weil sonst müssen wir ja
immer nur hoffen dass putin nichts macht
oder sehe ich das falsch gesehen das
absolut falsch
absolute top star gast putin das nicht
tun würde ich glaube was ich glaube ist
völlig irrelevant aber in der tat glaube
nicht dass es tun wird der mann hat eine
yacht die fünf millionen euro gekostet
hat er hat mehrere sehr wertvolle
immobilien und zwar nicht in berlin
wilmersdorf sondern einen ganz anderen
lokal ich glaube dass der mann fiel zu
satt und viel zu fett und viel zu
zufrieden und viel zu reich ist um einen
automaten niedergang zu riskieren aber
er weiß genau dass er mit dieser drohung
hier im westen erfolg haben kann und
bereits ein erfolg hat und ich glaube
vielleicht verzeihung das ist auch
anfänger wir haben jetzt sehr sehr
theoretisch über krieg gewinnen oder zu
einem ende führen geredet aber
tatsache ist doch dass jetzt schon die
ukraine die letztlich in der
erwartungshaltung viel schwächer
gestartet ist militärisch als die russen
inzwischen sich mit seiner einer
russischen armee die auch massive
verluste erlitten hat de facto nicht in
allen details war de facto einen
stellungskrieg lieber das heißt wir
reden bei allem respekt vor
militärischen eskalation wir reden über
eine russische armee die so weit hinter
allen internationalen erwartungen zurück
geblieben ist weil es nämlich massive
defizite massive defizite gibt
morgen ist dann nicht zu gewinnen ist ja
aber in afghanistan auf zwölf mal
geschieht ist immer da sehe ich nicht so
krieg ist immer furchtbar aber jetzt vor
einem putin und einer kaputten
russischen armee zurückzuweichen den
ukrainern zu empfehlen das zu tun das
wäre als würde ich uns seine lieder
militärisch hingucken sagen da ist
nichts zu gewinnen die russische armee
ist in einer solchen ober macht das
selbst wenn wir den ukrainern waffen
geben um so verändert haben dass
die sanierung der ukraine und dann haben
wir auf die nächsten 10 jahren daher
jetzt ein paar zeit wurde für kissler da
kommt
viel über die lösung gesehen wo sich
alle hier sehr uneinig kann man sagen
sie wenn sie das alles jetzt hier hören
was ihnen ihre ansicht
kontroverse solange sie friedlich ist
gut insofern schön dass wir uns streiten
aber was ich wirklich also gefährlich
mag ich das wort aber was ich für nicht
zielführend halte ist wenn man sich zu
sehr in das konnten den kopf versucht
hineinzuversetzen dieses aggressors also
was hat denn putin jetzt sich überlegt
was könnte er sich als nächstes
überlegen wenn wir dies oder jenes nicht
machen ich finde eigentlich es geht
darin zunächst einmal ganz einfach darum
den einfachen satz hat herr scholz
ausgesprochen am ersten mai in
düsseldorf unser bundeskanzler
russland hatte der ukraine nichts zu
suchen das klingt jetzt sehr simpel aber
dass zunächst war die grundlage aller
debatten die wir führen russland hat in
der ukraine nicht zu suchen egal war in
der geschichte zurückgehen russland hat
heute nichts in der ukraine zu suchen
der zweite punkt ist die ukraine sendet
hilfe rufen uns an den westen auch und
besonders in deutschland wie gehen wir
mit diesen hilfen an dass mit ihm ja
aber wir haben sie nicht hinreichen 710
wir haben sie nicht hinreichend wir
haben teilweise lächerlich gemacht mit
den stimmen von von der
schon wieder zu unterbrechen das ist
auch jetzt nicht der zeitpunkt ist jetzt
zu sagen schon wir haben als deutschland
genug getan ich glaube wir haben stand
heute nicht genug getan kein
blankoscheck für die nächsten jahre
hinein jetzt nicht wieder sozusagen
einen schönen lenz zu machen
anführungszeichen und zu sagen also wir
haben eure wunschliste eingedampft das
kriegt ja jetzt und jetzt die nächsten
monate machen wir erstmal eine
friedenssichernde maßnahmen eigenen land
unterhalten uns über die ziele die wir
verfolgt ich glaube momentan hat die
ukraine ein anrecht auf nicht nur
rhetorische unterstützung was ist genug
dass das werden wir im gang ist im gang
des weges sehen wir jetzt zurück krieg
aber momentan kommt ist glaube ich
darauf an die militärische unterstützung
bis zu einem punkt zu führen denn sie
bisher glaube ich nicht so im blick
haben bis zu einem punkt an dem es
möglich ist die russen in eine
verhandlungssituation zu zwingen das ist
doch möglich das ist die frage ich denke
schon hier ich glaube ich habe ihm
damals das ist ja ich glaube nicht dass
russland er verhandelt die stärker ist
auftritt und die geringer der widerstand
ist auf dem das trifft es glaube ich
nicht und dann liegt die frage genau wo
ist dieses genug und wo ist dieser punkt
ja und können wir den kalkulieren und so
weiter und so weiter und wieviel mario
puls und buddhismus es bis dahin geben
das ist die frage die wir diskutieren ja
und diese werden nicht entscheidend wie
wir uns anstrengen wäre
immerhin schon mal eingegrenzt ja also
das ist ja schon mal relativ vernünftig
ja zu sagen wir grenzen weil diese frage
ein und trotzdem ist ja um dieses genug
ist ja ein wirklich sehr dehnbarer
begriff war geprägt von radio
entschieden wer in deutschland wird
nicht sehr wichtig muss demokratisch
entschieden werden nicht durch
meinungsumfragen leider auch nicht durch
diskussionsrunden wir hier sondern eben
im wunderland' gar nicht am ingenieur
keiner wie weit sie bereit sind zu gehen
ja aber im dorf stehen tatsächlich als
zuschauer dabei aber die verantwortung
die deutschland hat muss auf
demokratischen leben das heißt im
bundestag entschieden werden da möchte
ich wirklich mal daran erinnern das ist
keine petitesse nicht meinungsumfragen
können sagen wir machen jetzt also wir
machen gar nichts das muss demokratisch
entschieden wie viel eine möglichkeit
wissen sie wir können nichts machen und
wir wollen keine truppen hinten und
unsere eingriffsmöglichkeiten
die bundeswehr die bundeswehr tätig und
ist wenn bundeswehr können wir
abschaffen ist eine friedens armee und
auch mit hunderten milliarden wird sie
nicht wieder auferstehen die bundeswehr
gegeben erreichte
russland für die armee das kann schon
sein aber bei uns versichert ist nicht
die lust haben wir noch ein aggregat
auch aber das also werden die ukraine
warten die bundeswehr ab also das
verstehe ich jetzt auch nicht habe oder
doch doch das ist ein komplizierter
vorgang
ach ja und ja ich habe einen sehr
praktikabel vorschlag kommt von einem
dänischen politiker dass namen ich
vergessen habe aus den 70er jahren
damals vorgeschlagene dänische armee
abzuschaffen anstelle dänischen armee
eine telefonnummer einzurichten die die
russen anrufen können und dann auf
russisch die botschaft zu geben lieber
russen wir haben soeben kapituliert und
wenn wir das machen ist dieser konflikt
vorbei für uns wirds aber auch gewisse
konsequenzen haben und die müssen sie
gern in kauf herr broder serie heute an
das letzte wort unsere sendung ist zu
ende das war ein spezial von villach die
sie vermutlich gemerkt haben denn das
thema ist so wichtig dass wir darüber
einmal monothematisch sprechen wollten
morgen abend sind wir dann wieder
klassisch für sie zurück ist schön haben
noch machen sie's gut